جت فتره انه
حطي عصافير في الصاله يعني ادخل زواج
والاقي اقزام داخلين معي ومدري وحركات
وكذا والاميره النائمه واللي مدري
وسندريلا وقامت وراحت تجيب الجزمه يعني ما
احس انه كاني عايشه فيلم كرتون
اسمي هدى الباز صار لي تقريبا 18 سنه في
المجال
ونقبله نار مخططه اعراس لو تزوجت بنتي
فاستعنت بشركه صراحه كانوا الشركه يعني
كانوا ذيك الايام من 18 سنه ما كان عندهم
يعني ما كان عندنا الشركات اللي
تبرد القلب على قولتهم خلاص الزواج وكنت
قاعده كذا مع نفسي ومتضايقه قولي يا الله
ليش يعني كذا يعني ليش ما مثلا ما يكونون
يعني
متحمسين يعني اكثر يكونوا متقنين اكثر
يكونون حرفيين اكثر في مجالهم قررت في
لحظتها اني ابدا هذا المجال يعني
اذا انت رحتي المنسق خلاص المفروض ترمين
عليها كل شيء
يعني انت ما تسالي المفروض
[موسيقى]
شوفي المجال هذا دخله في ناس كثير للاسف
اللي فاهم واللي مو فاهم يبين انا لما اجي
اقعد مع لما يجي يقولك بعمل لك وبسوي لك
وبعمل لك تبغين زي كذا ابدا واسوي لك
واعملك اذا قال لك ما عندي عقود هذا
انحاشي منه
[موسيقى]
معليش
ليش ما عندك عقود لازم يكون عقود والعقود
في بنود وتقرير عقدك زين ما زين تقرين
بنودك زين ما زين لان احيانا تكون اشياء
مبهمه يجي يوم الزواج ليش ما حطيت لي انا
معاه 200 لا والله ما قلتي لنا مثلا يعني
ما قلتي لنا نعم عزيمه والله نحسب معازيمك
ميه لازم تقرين كل بنت مزبوط ايش مكتوب
فيه عدد الضيوف عدد الكنائ مو عدد الكنب
عدد الضيوف
ينكتب جنب الكنب
لانه في ناس يحاسبونك على الكنبه
[موسيقى]
ما كان الناس تعرف ايش يعني اضاعه في
الزواج
خلاص كشاف عروس وبس وانتهينا كشاف العرس
بدل ما يزينها يشيينها بدل ما يزين العروس
يشيلها من جد يعني لانه اضاءه
بيضاء فتبين
تشوهات الميك اب وكده
صاروا يعرفون الحين صاروا يقول لا ما نبي
كشاف عروس نبي اضاءه من فوق ما في ما في
ديكور بسيط مره بس كوشه فقط لا غير وين
الحين الحين كانت قاعده تبني بني انا
قاعده تبنين فعلا تبنين تبنين كوشه تبني
الممرات تبني مداخل تبنين جدران بالصاله
حتى الصاله صرنا نسوي لها جدران كامله
عشان نقدر نحط الديكور اللي احنا نبغاه
عليها
[موسيقى]
يعني مثلا ليش حطيتي ذي الفازه هنا ليش
حطيتيها طيب هي العروس اللي طالبتها انت
ما كنتي موجوده في الميتنج اللي احنا
سويناه مثلا
هذا مو هذا اللون اللي انا اخترته مثلا
اجي اقول له لا هذا هو اللون اللي ابدا
طبعا انت ما تقدرين تشدين معها في يوم
الزواج
تقولي ايش تبين
غيره غير لك اياه
ترجعين تجيبين مثلا
السامبل حق الالوان او كذا وش تبيني يلا
بسرعه قولي ايش تبغين اي لون ترجع تختار
نفس اللون فتقولي لي حطيت لك نفس اللون
تغسل اعتبريه هي صح
هو نفسه موجود
[موسيقى]
شوفي الزوجات البسيطه اللي نتكلم عليها
مثلا بالبيوت يكون مره كوشه صغيره ناعمه
ترتيبات طاولات كنبات مداخل كذا اشياء
بسيطه خمسين الف في ناس يشوفونها مره
كثيره خمسين الف انه مثلا عدد ضيوف ستين
خمسين
بس فيها تكلفه ترى بالنسبه لزوجات يعني
الوسط 80 90% هذا الوسط
[موسيقى]
اللي فوق الوسط لا من 200 الف وطالع في
زواجات توصل بمبالغ
مو سهله صراحه
يعني او بس تشوفين تشوفين انه فعلا في شغل
[موسيقى]
انه
حطي عصافير في الصاله
معليش يعني جد فتره ترى عصافير حمام مدري
ايش في الصاله يعني قد جتني عروس طلبت
منها شيء ورفضت انا انه قفص وينفتح الطير
العصافير
عرفتي جت هذه الفتره فانا كنت ضدها تماما
ما ادري يمكن طيور حب او شيء زي كذا يعني
هذا معناته وانه طاقه انه انطلقوا يعني ما
نفهمه والله بس تجيك العصافير اللي في في
الصاله تدور يعني
هذه ابدا ما انا بالعكس هذه
ممكن تسوي اي شيء في الصاله اللي تدخل لي
بعربه مثلا عربه سندريلا
واحده جت قالت لي ابغى شو اسمه هذا
الاميره النائمه ولا مدري ايش هذه اللي
تدخل الاقزام السبعه ما ادري زي كذا يعني
حركات سندريلا مدري ايش زي كذا
فقلت لها هذه
هبه انت تحسينها شيء زين كانت ذيك الايام
جاءت فتره كذا يدخلون بعربه
وما ادري ايش قلت له
انك سويتيها لانه شيء يضحك يعني ادخل زواج
والاقي اقزام داخلين معي ومدري وحركات
وكذا والاميره النائمه والمدري وسندريلا
وقامت وراحت تجيب الجزمه يعني ما احس انه
كاني عايشه فيلم كرتون خليك ستاندر عادي
عروسه داخله وش حليلك
[موسيقى]
عقدي واضح مجرد ما تقرا العقد تعرف انه
انه ما بتطلع لها ما يطلع لها الشغل الا
قبل الزواج مكمل باسبوعين المبلغ
صارت لي قصص زي كذا يعني للاسف للاسف يعني
صارت لي قصه مع وحده
وثقت فيها للاسف طلعت لها زواج كامل على
مسئوليتي انا
ولليوم ما دفعت
اليوم ما دفعت
وعدتني اني ان شاء الله بعد الزواج انا
عندي ظروف
وبعد الزواج على طول هدفعلك
ممر يوم يومين ثلاثه اربعه خمسه شهر شهرين
ان شاء الله لا اكيد اكيد مستحيل ما تدفع
مستحيل كيف واحده تزوج بنتها وما تدفع كيف
يعني كيف صارت ما ترد علينا
[موسيقى]
طنش مكالماتنا
يعني صارت تتهرب يعني الزواج بنتها صار
على حسابي انا يعني انا تكلفت بزواج بنتها
انا شوفي لو ما اعشقها المهنه ما استمريت
لحد الحين لاني اعشقها احبها
لو رجع فيني زمن حاختار شيء شبيه فيها بس
مو هي اكلت من صحتي ممتعه وحلوه
وفيها
متعه لما تخلصين وتسلمين الشغل وتكون
العروس مبسوطه واهلها مبسوطين وسعيدين
تكونين انت معاهم سعيده تكون مثلا زفت
وراحت هي وزوجها تفاجئ برساله منها
يعني ما هي فاضيه لي شلون ترسل لي الحين
ترسل لي يعني بصوت وتشكره ومبسوطه
وسعيده ويعني
كل مره مره انسى كل شيء اصلا انسى كل
التعب الله يعطيك العافيه الله يعافيك يا
رب خلصنا خلصناه بس استاذنك
[موسيقى]
اه كذا
هذه نضبط الصوت مع الصور يلا
شكرا